this was
homes these were people's homes
but they got swept up
in the conflict
let's pause here
if you zoom out and look at where we're
at right now you can see that i'm moving
through these dashed lines
i've been moving in and out of these
dashed lines all week this is a border
crossing but every time i call these
things borders i get corrected we do not
use the term
uh porsche these are two ceasefire lines
these are not borders yeah so cyprus
remains one country there's one member
state within the united nations yes the
lines and what you call them are very
sensitive here but it's hard to deny
that they still feel like borders they
exist like borders in that their goal is
to divide people
this right here for example is a
crossing through one of these dashed
lines to get into the north of this
island into a self-declared country a
country that no one recognizes besides
turkey and it's supposedly not a real
border crossing this crossing over here
that's not a border crossing sure felt
like a border crossing there are
gates and passport booths and customs
and pcr tests so did i just enter into a
new country
no but kind of
i'll let you decide
there is no greek cypriot politician who
supports a two-state solution
these lines are ambiguous they're
emotional they're political and you can
learn a lot about them simply by
crossing them
i now i am driving on the left side of
the road for the first time in my entire
life
and i can't tell you that i feel calm
about it
which is why i came to this island
cypress to cross as many of these lines
as i could to understand them these
lines that envelop towns that cut up
farmland bleed into the ocean
and infamously cut this capital city in
half
making it the last divided capital on
has many earth and many times english
armenian french arabic christian and
muslim as a result the turks hold more
than two-thirds of the island's wealth
nearby liberal street has been known as
murder greeks and turks live uneasily
side by side nicosia capital city of
cyprus the center of the bitter struggle
between greek and turk is engulfed in
war
let's make one thing clear despite what
you might be thinking after you watched
episode 1 cyprus is not a war zone it's
not all military barriers and troops
quite the opposite this place is
actually a tourist's paradise not too
far from all the barriers 2 million
tourists a year most of them british can
be found sunbathing in these beautiful
mediterranean waters the largest city
and capital called nicosia feels like
many other cities full of shops and
stores people going about their lives
but if you walk around here long enough
you'll start to notice that a lot of
these streets stop at an abrupt dead end
these dead ends are made up of military
barriers sandbags barbed wire military
outposts soldiers with guns and flags
lots of flags these dead ends are the
dashed lines you see when you look at
google maps the ones that cut through
this city but in real life these lines
are not dashed they're not porous these
are actually very thick lines that
successfully divide this city into the
greek side to the south
[Music]
and the turkish side to the north
[Music]
and in the middle there's space
sometimes thick sometimes thin a space
that is given this sterile name the
buffer zone and remember these are
ceasefire lines not borders
at least not according to any greek
cypriot or un official that you talk to
but call them what you want on paper i
want to see what these dashed lines
actually feel like when you cross them
in reality this space this buffer zone
is a scar a messy series of curves that
in the 60s and 70s acted as a sort of
shock absorber in a war that ripped this
city and island apart it was the united
nations that helped hastily draw these
lines to stop the fighting between the
greek and turkish sides to keep these
two groups who had lived side by side
for centuries away from each other here
in the center of nicosia
the narrowest part of the buffer zone is
only three meters from one side to the
other side two soldiers on balconies on
either side of the street could touch
each other
i spent time in both the turkish and
greek sides of nicosia but i really
wanted to get a peek over these walls
into that ambiguous space that used to
be the central downtown but now lay
locked between these dashed lines
so i'm on a roof now that is in the
middle of nicosia the capital
and i am walking closer and closer to
this buffer zone this scar that rips
through the center of the city the
republic of cyprus effectively ends
right here and right there that street
is no man's land
i mean that's the north right there like
i'm looking across the border into
northern cyprus
this was just a normal part of the city
but because of the fighting
the line pushed back and forth and back
and forth and eventually settled here
but it wasn't always like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm now down on the street walking in
this no
land it just really gets thin i mean
right
man's
it's like
we've been in places where it's really
wide but right here is 30 meters
greek side turkish side
right there you can look above
and just looking at these businesses and
these homes
you can envision them alive and
thriving and this street seems like a
very busy main street with
all of these uh businesses and places
and these signs that are just left one
greek cypriot's house was right here her
name was annie and she refused to leave
she lived here for decades with the un
soldiers often bringing her her
groceries her front door walked right
out into the buffer zone right in the
crosshairs of turkish military it would
have been within their right to fire if
she walked out into this buffer zone and
yet she remained and then in the 90s she
died of old age here in her home she was
91. the soldiers removed her body they
gave her a funeral and according to the
reports at the time her body was the
last thing to leave her home
everything else stayed frozen in time
much like the rest of this buffer zone
we're in a wool shop an old wool shop
and the owner's records are just here
like just spread out on this table goods
of italian origin this guy
had quite the business there was
commerce there was
an economy there was trade there was
this place was thriving
and then it just collapsed
i you're absolutely right the buffer
zone is a unique environment the reality
is is that since
1974 the buffer zone has been a de facto
area of
very
little human activity
yeah and what has happened as a result
is the ecology of the buffer zone is
unique to this island
you will find species of
plant and fauna here in the buffer zone
that you will not find anywhere else
this divided capital and the time
capsule buffer zone that cuts it in half
is one face of this divided island but
as you drive you soon see other versions
of it
as i moved into the eastern part of this
island it turned from divided city into
these british bases and then more and
more you start to see rural parts of
this island
[Music]
and yet the dashed line continues even
all the way out here it spans 180
kilometers from east to west um further
to the east of the island is are the
flat farmlands of the buffer zone
where we see a lot of farming activity
so one thing you see in the buffer zone
is a bunch of
farmland like people's homes and land
that they had to leave in 1974.
unsurprisingly
this was a giant loss for a lot of
families and so the u.n actually allows
them to come back in to their old land
and cultivate it so in addition to all
of these farms there's also
mine fields
this was where people lived and
was just a part of cyprus
but for the past several decades
this has just been no man's land
in many ways farm life within the buffer
zone is similar to farm life anywhere
else i started growing tomatoes
and i think
this land all i put tomatoes i planted
tomatoes
but there i have their peppers over
jeans i have to fix the land to clean it
yeah but every day there are harsh
reminders of what has become of this
farmer's land of his home his work here
is so distinctly juxtaposed to what you
can see in the distance turkish military
outposts barbed wire fences uns courts
growing political tensions and yet every
day that passes this becomes a more
permanent fixture of life on this island
it's the world terrible thing i remember
everything and because i i've been in a
school for one year if i'm augusta i was
12
and we started the rejuvenation there
and after the war
even despite all of this greek cypriots
insist that their country is not divided
when you use the the 10 poster that
means
even us ourselves we have already
divided our country and cyprus uh
is is is not divided is occupied
uh
uh 35 percent of the of the island of
cyprus is occupied and while that's true
according to the map and to the
international community the fact remains
that this division is very real so real
that it's embedded itself into the minds
of people young and old who live here
and i remember when i was in primary
school when i was first grade and i've
always seen the secret flag as divided
so i was always seeing the red line and
we had to color the flag and have
actually
drew it yeah and
the teacher was like georgia we're not
you know we're not divided
[Music]
but as a kid you just thought that
that's how it was
so i think it's the experiences that we
get from
like very young and it's very difficult
to get rid of these emotions i think in
1974 effectively the two communities
have been divided and we have seen
generations of young people since
1974 who have not had any contact with
the other side
and the power of these lines isn't how
they affect the treaties and the peace
talks and the diplomats but instead how
they stop the sides from seeing each
other from humanizing one another
leading to only more polarization when
people were referring to the other side
we were thinking that there was no life
and was just ghosts as kids because when
people die they also go to the other
side when we had the first experience of
crossing from the
checkpoint
we did have a hesitation that
what will happen when people hear us
talking in turkish
and what will their reaction be
so while the un might not recognize
these as borders they serve the same
purpose to divide people both physically
and mentally from one another i was born
in a divided island and then i can see
that in the last 20 years
nothing has changed it's really changed
for me so
um
i can't say that like and even hope that
we had as children i think that now
there's nothing to keep our faith up
so it just seems that
even if change comes it's not something
immediate it's not something that will
come like soon and yet even though the
younger generation grew up with these
barriers in their country and in their
minds that has also allowed them to see
these lines more clearly to question
them in a way that the older generation
never could do you think that the
younger generation has more of an
appetite for unity than maybe the older
generations who experience some of the
violence history teaches us that turkish
spirits and greek cypriots live together
side by side yeah for many many years
before the conflict
they they share the same history they
share the same culture they eat many of
the same foods
and that gives us hope that
peace is possible and the young
generation perhaps are at the forum
leading that effort
thank you betterhelp for sponsoring
today's video betterhelp is a platform
that makes therapy more accessible and
more secure for everybody regardless of
where you live i've been in therapy for
a couple of years now and i can't tell
you how much it has changed my world
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with a licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating
with that therapist within 48 hours
which if you've ever looked for a
therapist
is a very quick turnaround it's not a
crisis line it's not a self-help thing
it's professional therapy that is done
securely on the internet finding the
right fit in a therapist is really
important and betterhelp has over 20 000
therapists in their network which is way
more than you would have in your local
area they want you to have a positive
experience and so they make it easy and
free to change your therapist if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available so go to betterhelp.com johnny
harris if this is interesting to you
you'll get 10 off your first month of
betterhelp so you can try it out at a
discounted price and see if it's a good
fit thank you betterhelp for sponsoring
today's video